("Dine With Kreisler" by Joseph Alexander)
- The first thing that you do is smell it.
Then you go to swirl it.
And then I find out what
does it do on your tongue.
Then you can really
experience the whole body
of the milk.
My name is Bas de Groot,
and I am the milk sommelier.
70% of your flavor experience
is created by smell.
My name is John Bucher,
and I'm a dairy farmer.
We're in the heart of the wine country,
which is not typically
known as dairy country.
- The main thing that I
do is telling the story
of the rich diversity of milk.
We come to waltz it.
- Is that what you call it, waltz it?
- Yeah, waltzing.
- We call it swirl.
- Oh okay, swirl.
Milk and wine are both
made from living products.
And one is made by soil and the plant,
and the other one is also made
by the soil and the plant,
but there is the cow between (cow moos).
We all think milk is
white, but only by seeing
these two milks, we see
that milk is not white.
- I see a really big difference in a way.
- Do you see it?
I think that milk can be
terroir, so where the cow lives,
in which landscape, like Sonoma County,
but also the farmer and
his vision and his dreams.
That's all part of the terroir.
- I'm very proud of what my parents did
to start this farm.
Next year, we'll be here for 60 years.
We operate a 700-cow organic dairy farm.
We produce 5,000 gallons of milk a day.
With that, I also farm
55 acres of wine grapes.
Those of us that farm have
a tremendous responsibility.
And that’s what's so exciting and fun for me,
to be part of that.
- John, what we have here is your milk.
This is the milk of Clover Sonoma Organic,
and we have the full-fats
and the two-percents.
This is like fresh, sweet,
and then also having
a long aftertaste.
Normally, I prefer the full-fat milk
because fat is the carrier of taste.
So, I'm really surprised
that I like two-percents.
It has flavor, that's great.
The milk, or the product of Farmer
John, is his own identity,
and it's also something
that you can experience
in the product.
Farming is really about balance.
As a farmer, you are standing
in front of an orchestra
and try to make a really cool symphony.
(cows moo)
This is my first time being in California,
and I've now tasted the milk.
You really can experience the quality.
This is good milk.